assistance our assembly point will be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic sweet please do not delay your
evacuations collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so or I
came back yes ma'am I'm holding team
Emma I believe we've been recording on
yes you need to advise goodbye remember
so thank you man you look at the the
meter will also be recording option but
started bad moments ago its own no such
thing thank you so apologies for absence
no not okay non members attending
casters thank you very much so the item
number three appointment of Chairman's
we have any nominations and not like
soon you know a cancer steptoe Chen I'll
be pleased to say that exactly okay
anyone else let me vote on yeah damn you
don't photothermal nomination thank you
very much appointments at vice chairman
do we have any what I think that is
going to him and it's the chamber that
takes over thank you and
document i absolutely key role in Charis
make it right what point minute advice
chairman have we any nominations well
I'd like to nominate accountants
counselor and medicine makes
intensifying a pleasure and I'll be
pleased to nominate dog and second even
if it would you nomination and yeah
thank you very much that's all right I
know you know it's good that we have a
non-party approach to this I know you're
very interested in it so I'm sure you'll
do it all thank you very much these are
than everyone else cream between very
clean to the northern of nations no
other nominations well I better give me
I'm not sure whether we should
congratulate each other each other or
not having we should hug each other
might have any feeling left John that
has been recorded that's fine I'm just
if you're a friendly and it's Christmas
what they know okay right item five
declarations of interest in so many
decorations are interested remind
members if anything should come up
Zoomer discussions please chapped I can
see its terms of reference that's on
your agenda does anybody wish to pick up
on this at all chevon this is a bit if I
make through you it's very new khaki so
mean that we've done this sort of thing
before so I'm assuming that these terms
of reference have been to look through
elsewhere or somewhere we've got mice
our legal team what's the usual way of
terminal in terms of reference were
actually imported full council and Basel
I'm not taking you to start the
investment world ok so we seen before so
again thank you very much for that pink
PS on this it's time around as a
visiting member obviously i'm interested
in arizona where of the fact that this
is all for us go and exactly what the
investment or does and how it works will
evolve over time we have what what was
your clearly chairman about the terms of
reference should they need to change or
what what is your ability to change them
should the need arise but it obviously
would have to go
two full council because they're very
buffle couch Nathan come correct the
same boat German if it helps yes it does
occur to me that there's an opportunity
for several meetings between now and the
next municipal year and when that annual
council meets it would be an opportunity
to perhaps if necessary visitor a tweet
movie the terms of reference did you
watch Kanye I would agree with that
approach I certainly understand accounts
like let's say we are we are going to
learn quite a lot as we go through the
process and if that sounds a little bug
The Apprentice it for our bees to a
certain extent I think there are you
know opportunities to set up where we
are and to boot from it if we if we come
across anything that doesn't work we've
got the opportunity of thinking to do
something about it quite quickly and
we've got four councils in the meantime
as well as the annual council lives or
something more you know more fundamental
and so I'm content with that personally
yep journey through you if I may just to
say if there is something that falls
with it outside the remit if you like of
those terms of reference that we do need
I mean I think perhaps you know if we
are able to revisit those and take them
to council took notice cliff we don't
want to say anything they might be
potential investment whatever then you
mean okay any other questions
you'll get used to playing tennis yes I
been like that and a second bullet point
can I ask when these outlines will be
starting to come through and will they
go to this committee or expecting them
an email I mean the time of this
committee re sitting I don't believe
this beg for it is that 22nd we had only
when 20 second example we have a whole
emitting the next week so next week so
next week you'll have this list mode
with up to make you wake up til 11 now
the thought practical main shipment was
that we'd have the discussion today
about how the committee operates and
then we were looking to bring a set of
an initial set of business cases in the
sense of more of a name only with it
with a little bit of detail as opposed
to any details within that if i make
sense I don't can I ask that we get them
with plenty of time prior to that
meeting there's the point Atlanta moment
so we can digest for taking things
Knobloch I've just been given if it's a
morrow that's my folks this is that
button any other question okay I think
that's just for noting at this stage i
think is it if ya okay thank you right
507 bottom I'm gonna go see someone I'm
just don't do things on it designs
himself Maggie not
it ended up board cultural progress I
don't Jess the message is it submarket
magic kick the deck cheerleader in the
dark as usual is Megan and so much focus
on those so what's your item sir pls yes
u deficit thank you okay no I'm going to
throw this philosopher Jacoby this limb
and began sing so we do ya say so you're
special yeah special needs another story
oh okay right item seven stroke 6 for
culture approach I who would like to
make a stars on this what's happening
Jackson gave you a few comments really
just a short report to try and set seed
for the way that Italy it's invisible
and I need will function I me nothing I
suppose the first thing to say is that
recognizing that the others of the
makeup of the wall of the committee is
is this dirty members I think there's
going to be a need as the work program
events for there to be smaller task
finish groups identified by the board
that will go away do piece of work and
then come back to to to the board for a
decision I think the second the second
point to make is that we need to ensure
that the board is working very much
towards the focus of it of the business
plan that is emerging from the prop from
the council I think we've highlighted at
that point in the in the reports of the
themes and objectives of the business
plan are going to be a key component
focus for the way that the work program
for the IB delivers its programme of
work over the next period and probably
the other point to make is that in terms
of the the project's themselves that
begin to emerge from the work of the
board we envisage that there would be a
fairly structured approach to the way
that those projects will be developed
with a project sponsor that's a member
from from the IV our project lead either
the chief executive or one of the
directors and then below that structure
of a project manager and other
appropriate have that as required
depending on the particular project
that's being that's being developed so
that's just a few sort of comments in
terms of thinking around heavily
will operate you've obviously got a
number of projects that you're looking
at and leaning forward we will be
expecting members to be coming forward
with ideas suggestions for things for
you to be looking at I see no reason why
ideas cannot come forward for members
that can be considered for a part of the
part of the work program as you
recovered went through the filthy away d
in salt air identify various various
projects and schemes that might be
considered as part of the the more
commercial approach for the for the
authority so absolutely no reason at all
why booze can't be considered but we
have to I think I'll ensure that the
work program that is developed by the by
the board is is manageable realistic and
deliverable we've got to looking at a
pic programmer I think I guess over the
next three four or five years rather
than you're trying to cram everything
into the next six months so there has to
be a realistic expectation of how that
will how that will function the only not
contract that do you think it would be
an idea for members to have a copy on
our Lowe's an electronic version of a
loop of the asset register although I
know it's not totally complete Jackson's
11 I think one of the one of the task
and finish groups i think probably the
vib might want to consider and i think
that will be absolutely for the for the
next meeting might my career will be a
review of the of the asset register i
think probably the only way of doing
that is to send there's several member
of nominating members off to to work
with officers on that on that particular
project i'm not sure the stage how long
land your boutique
that's something we'll look at k celebs
coming no okay alien but thank you Kevin
yeah it's just on a reference to
resource implications 7.1 I noticed that
on item 6 the previous item we had
flagged up excess for 25,000 but it just
wasn't mentioned again although
obviously no decision has been taken out
the the progress the funds needed to
product obvious but that 25,000 was
originally flagged up as a guesstimate
in item in the second in the
pre-designed licenses to Germany the
terms of reference make specific simply
the schemes in business cases that the
the board would work on we relate to
schemes and projects that require a new
investment in excess of 25,000 it wasn't
necessary everything okay there wasn't
necessarily setting you know a fund for
the dogger to actually pursue its work i
think the point I was making in the
report was that there be a need for for
a fund and that something's got to be
finalized through the through the budget
and surely anybody else yet son Sarang
factory members plus well thank you
cheering and as the role of the board
and evolves and decisions are made I
think it's important to establish what
we can do as a council in as far as for
instance forming different companies or
even charities or things like that it
would be nice to know what the
parameters are there presumably are
allowed to form companies if we see
Sophie
the answer is yes though I think the
decision to do that we probably probably
be in full council and necessarily in
the IV but yes the council can forward
on this I think that will certainly be
part of the the overall ambition in
terms of some of the projects and
proposals that know you want to work for
so we will be looking to recommend total
count so I think probably in the case of
form a company would have to be to full
council the decision if I mentioned the
decision on the investment could come
from here because it's a committee of
full council that investment but a
vehicle yeah but they don't have to go
to the full council program operates
angle bracket okay sorry I'm visiting
tonight with my partners as portfolio of
the fire hi Nancy job that the leaders
charge me with and with that hat on I've
got a couple of questions clearly you're
going to be looking to to make vestments
and we've got the the section 1151
officer to ensure that you don't do
anything that essentially bonkers
immoral or illegal however it's only the
potential to make unwise decision now
you are going to need a pot of money to
do something with and the moment you
start investigating land property
development you you you take on
professional feeds and it my roller I
wanted to be confident that it's the
committee or board that is determining
what that job role is remember led as
opposed to officer that so I wouldn't
like to see that the simply list of work
by officers and they get on with it up I
want to understand that there is the the
proper oversight of the committee and
then also as the developments come
closer clearly the financial
implications or some things are
particularly concerned with we obviously
got the potential to set up a company
and we maybe got some protection from
that but it's just understanding the
mechanics of quite how that would work
now I'm not a member of this board and i
think if i were there be a conflict of
interest but with with my my portfolio
hat on i just wanted to be absolutely
sure about where the financial input is
injected into the way in which the board
is going to work so is the question
simon the mechanics of have a project or
go through why as a new a new board you
perhaps haven't got that these are not
yet on it and it might not evolve until
where you're actually faced with making
a decision or a concrete accomplish
chosen as it evolves the proposal would
be there a project project area that
would have any member or members
sponsoring interest are but the fact
that make sense of the member sponsor on
that with the full detail about what the
outcomes were seeking what that project
is except as you'd expect from from any
any pin basically you know maybe maybe a
large bit maybe a small pit in fact does
that make sense so within that then
there will be the governance issues
which is around finance legal etc so all
of those would obviously be ticked off
when it comes back here for members but
the project sponsor would oversee think
that
yeah I did not your question is I
understand I understand the over side
but it's it's where it comes to the
financial examination at a member level
or is the question whether it's about
you come from I'd I don't know well
maybe that even more pointed them put
but that's where I get to your question
coming from I think just there's two
aspects you've got you've got a budget
enable yourselves to carry out the work
and then you've got a budget proposal
for the investment to two separate items
at least in this case does the term now
we did visit you for me I mean able to
visit that's left the role of the board
to to scrutinize the Assam veracity the
financial elements of a scheme that are
coming forward by whatever means that
you deem appropriate whether it be you
know return on investment or whatever
you know which is a standard we're doing
these things but word that needs to
scrutinize those issues with the dress
from relevant advice trip from officers
just throw our hands in the air like you
were coming engagement possibly linked
to a counselor Smith I just wondering
how this links in with portfolio holders
for instance and I think he thinks is so
much more catalyst beside because the
portfolio helpers come back bc Justin
I'm natural value or over or around
50,000
have in excess of fifty thousand that
could go back I think imma go around
we're making decisions over 25,000 we're
making decisions apparently on projects
which would involve one or more
portfolio holders and I'm wondering how
they are dieting tips that the process
as well if it's just remember later a
member from the investment bond how does
it link into the prevailing over as well
I mean wouldn't seem reasonable from the
portfolio's point of view that
something's happening without their
knowledge in the investment ball because
they may not be on the investment gold
and I would help sue that networking I
don't want it unless a miracle I'm
trying to not allow these questions but
actually difficulties and I'm having
difficulty of the sale of difficulty and
how involved is a portfolio holder in a
project when it might well be part of
that pool photo holders responsibility
ok so the projects that say it's a
projects coming forward for take acids
and take 57 south street for example
just to sit up and we want to develop
their shoes a lot of examples okay
alright the music that has the example
again said currently it just happens to
be with councillor step tones put money
in terms of assets etc so if that's
coming forward here he would have he
would have size of that I've seen that
being a conflict in terms of the
investment that this committee is then
taking forward because it doesn't need
to be a computational adversarial
element towards that because the
investment and then the weather and the
projects are coming forward to this bulb
you'll be based on a grid set of
principles and an agreed set of projects
coming forward when they'd also be
appropriate life review committee to
have a portfolio her along to a
particular inner inception but project
and project radiation
to ensure that that input is given I
don't see a problem if that is the way
we work and that's party probably talk
about that you find out I think you need
to be understood I think it's not work
in that way in the in the a final bit
about there in the involvement of a
portfolio holder I think it could be
quite heat as a matter of con Section B
involves to sound every pop fire hoses
on the floor anyway thank you I want to
leave why would there be for looking for
alternative expert advice so now we have
sort of been looking into offices as
well but you know I would look something
like to be able to go outside of that
and ask for other advice the ball
directly can they buy into advice and as
they want to look at I think that's
going to be very very important you know
part of what we're going to do breve a
completely I think that's a given I
suspected and that's where initial
budget actually that's it has the enemy
know you were thrusting terribly wasn't
coming i need to say if you look at the
approach item for and 4.3 i think it
does explain our project sort of going
through if you have a look at 4.07 point
why I think it really you know it sort
of sets out the arrangements I do agree
that own I mean all members get on
papers on on this committee so any
portfolio holder won't be in the dark
about anything that's going on the only
thing got might be different perhaps be
the detail it might come forward but any
portfolio got filled up with an
interesting network that's all I want to
either consult members of this committee
already come along as you rightly say
and indeed we may want to talk to the
ball player hover as you quite rightly
say as well so I think all those things
of you know all the cards that we hold
got me complaining of them in some be
one you're marking you al questions
can I plant my sight in Texas and we
spoke to you under the terms of
reference so there will be an outline of
the broad basis for all of the project
but we currently have in couple of the
officers happening contemplation plus
those going from members if they choose
to pass them through Shawn's garden
walls which is executive one assumes
that we will also start to flesh out the
program plan and that's just not a list
of things in terms of reference that
would be how these would fit together in
a time scale it goes to be honest we
might see the asset register the asset
and now register analysis taking place
over six months that doesn't mean that
this this committee would have nothing
to look at for six months because then
we can start another project and
actually run that in in parallel to it
and therefore you know set off a number
of projects at the same time all of
which take into account the resources we
have available and the important thing
in this is to remember that under
sufficient administrative resources
which is under the terms of reference
we're going to need a project office
because there is quite clear with the
program of this size importance and
dimension we're going to have to put
aside the project office with with an
officer or two officers maybe even three
when it gets running to actually keep
very close tabs on both budgets which of
course they have the benefit of the
resources assistant director and the 151
officer but more particularly to ensure
that we we actually keep to a pretty
strict time scale and we know when
something's not going right and
therefore we can recognize the risks and
seek to recognize those risks
appropriately so you know don't get over
concerned about the fact that we're
ain't talking about a couple of things
we can talk about many things and let
them run but they run under a pleasant
so given the proximity of the budget
setting process can I make a request
that of your next meeting because of
22nd that you do try and populate some
idea of the initial path they will need
as a working capital so that that can go
into the budget process don't see that
as a problem they're not in this end but
then Jimmy honey just just very briefly
on the on point on what me back at the
Nixon week we will be anticipated it
will indeed for a couple of officers who
will give focus to the developing
program and the management or football
for that so you know that that rule that
will be in place as part of the priority
of the arrangements for the board any
other questions it's just a question
general having at that puppy the asset
register is that distinct from the
council tebya I was at least a woman
worth area but I didn't catch what boys
Tevye yes it's it's a more abundant word
for I think I think at the air to tell
you it was a sort of meh sleuthing
wasn't it good with cancel red lines of
the Council of the plan it it is it is
the modern term you can learn something
today I don't know that
a long time ago train and with both of
you guys wondering but where they keep
the council champion if I border before
comes in system do you feel irregularly
by this size in any other questions okay
you've got a recomendation at nine point
one on the page seven pointer could you
imagine okay so chairman just one
without question I might have them mr.
the rapport on the preliminary reports
coming to us in the 22nd mom we receive
that just a wee confused if automation
before I try and get it done with Inga
normally take an x-ray then forward
could be 94 the 17th sounds like a
weekday could be 94 that and give us fun
it's just a broad five calendar days
thank you okay just through Chairman I
mean it might be an idea because we both
got busy diaries just to get a set of
dates through get so that we can
organize some dates so that we can take
this forward you know rather than sort
of doing off the hook if you like
clearly they met there might be regular
meetings you may need to call a special
meeting from time to time relating to a
specific investment is coming forward or
whatever but you know that's obviously
you know any open your computer so you
have to leave that with you but you know
it's let's get some tastings re soon as
we can okay well Lester with Reverend
I'm sorry if we're not members of
we get notification of when the meetings
will be on an invisible as he loves
going out of the general drop so one
final question which I think they come
up in a meeting last week because
pertinence this makes an r-rated game
even though know the answers given
they're not serious the same answer now
although it says that I've closed I
don't have a better it mentions that
part of the financial nature will be led
by members of the investment bulb it
doesn't bring got just like off make you
don't preclude members who aren't
members of the investment board bleeding
on projects yes that same answer I don't
think the tape would have heard it yes
those so are significant okay right back
to the recommendation is everybody happy
with the recommendation on real
improvement okay right taking on the
points about dates we have already got
one in the diary for the 20 seconds is
everybody happy with that dates let's
hear it for 730 730 ksi p.m. and there
is some time to other dates that have
been set aside firstly the fourth of
februari and wednesday the 16 to march a
jamar parties place for a December 1 i'm
not be home
chairman door any second of send off a
road other than that is everybody don't
know anything to these 7 13 13 you know
the usual so that's the 22nd december
the fourth of februari for the sixteenth
of option okay are you happy with that
you okay that seems today and listen
anything else anybody else [ __ ] he wants
to rise I think we'll just pack up step
up such a timid like the meeting today
look close budget